les monstres les démons les fantômes ou
encore les sorcières l'horreur selon moi
il s'agit d'un genre mineur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rien de tout ça est arrivé on en
reparlera plus jamais on va tous le
jurer
[Musique]
la gamine
l'influenceur la bibliothécaire la
bombasse la protagoniste
l'écorché et l'ami des filles
on est seulement les pires fanatiques de
l'horreur de l'université
[Musique]
ils devront à présent payer de leur vie
par conséquent dans chaque chapitre de
ce roman un membre du Club meurt
la personne qui a écrit ce truc était
forcément là ça doit être quelqu'un du
club Angela n'a pas confiance en toi
chapitre le clown vient juste de le
publier
c'est comment identifier
tout le monde a fait à cause de moi en
plus